[музика]
праві дроїди цим при з вами думками
творчий за missoni
сьогодні не стільки в джетті нас благаю вас
[музика]
так майже я не знаю
заїхати за маленькою стравою
чим встановлювати маленькі кашель та
давай показуй що ми
працюємо арочку у є вже в челсі
тому лева ти і так бачу букси руки в
щоб сидіти два пальці
[музика]
цукру
самого локи пальчик ось після пальчик
мого обидва у та вісь про2 нас кришка з
танцями та ми компаній
а ти давай не солі пана сходив на
кеті я зоб'ю на знали б ти зовсім не
подібну накрити ну а даю 100 я довірюсь
твоєму
судів розум і стати скуму меню
покажи правда петя
[музика]
обманювати їх називаєш слухаючи пальчику
бульвар david koma
[музика]
гармату
бастет
[музика]
це ліворуч на
терку.
я почну ротом
[музика]
клас мені навіть з
підкладкою пух нас велику піцу на
губах звільнять вже сталевим бали свої
пальчики вона тут пса 5 / і ми в самару
його ти допомагаємо з на прогулянку виступав
вікна моя я канал подібне до таких людей
правду
[музика]
всім
привіт друзі свами поні цефея є і
[музика]
хочу
дівчинку-то продажу тузова цілу
дівчинку і вас розуміє sexual поля а і
суперсила ну щож але ми пачино ти і нас
сьогодні історія дуже васала друзів
жила-була одна така дівчинка завжди
чи називалася син мана спрага передала з
пари потужний смак ведмедика і після знав
на бананами та шкірки наше дівчисько
заходилася сміху з'являється
від коли з казимова на вступала у болоту
то вона разу мило що отримала чудову на
воду піст риба ти колесах
на ці будуть вже вашого вона сміялася
сама з мішни la всіх навколо про мережу
лушпиння товари а в рюкзаку у дівчинки
буму тоді тактних смажте до
жити та когось тому la продумати цю
смішну історію і тим самим розсмішить і
всіх навколо а в рукаві у на і
blu-50 до найму вірних вийти так
зайве з початку історії різанину 1 по
кодеку на злизнула він лише кит
подобається було але також смішно щось на і
важливі лише і що дівчина lesya спраги
знала я кредит йдуть грибних труднощі
хатинку та
знає і кобилу і суперсилу
[музика]
точну
стільця почуття помру а
джек мур
у нас три страви на шоу з людей на
мужику лось розмішає про італію цілий
нас 3 цифри будинку і нас дуже а то мої
васали не що в нього теж була його
цілий нас три точно спраги
висоли не
дуже вас ціла історія
така чи просто супер сила так я
обожнюю вам теж ніби таким його самим і
щасливим і я виношу дівчисько
[музика]
так гриф ну і
таюся т.п. засіла але ми просимо та
символи василій ноті голи для вас цього
застиглий обидва
[музика]